I think that we ought to change our
Town's slogan a great place to call home
is confusing I suggest a great place to
refer to as home we need a crosswalk on
Trent Avenue between Frost and Allegheny
and also
[Music]
oh my our UFO it crashed my backyard has
taken out my azaleas and destroyed my
bird bath and
did you just say UFO
what is that you remember the spaceship
this is the little man who came out of
it he's got to be a secret don't tell
anybody
[Music]
she shouldn't know we gotta trust her
there's nothing else we can do you could
kill her kill me
please stop it you think we can call
them Jewels he's not Jules he's more of
a Gary your dad was in here earlier he
said he was buying apples for an alien
like an illegal alien
thank you for the picture he hands them
to me all the time maybe he's trying to
tell you something dad cool I'm worried
what you have said
normal I'm okay how can you can you say
that when you're buying apples for an
alien
[Music]
the government is searching for the
security satellite that crashed any
moment we waste is a moment they can
discover him you're seeing the movies
you know what happens to
just when they fall to Earth
break the sky wide open Jules has come
to me quite a bit to us
it's about Dad buying apples for an
alien
last four hanging out together we got
along pretty well we're so thankful for
you
there you got me
[Music]
what the